[Musique]
un jour dix minutes après le début d'une
expérience dans mon laboratoire
mon poisson a perdu un oeil
avec les autres animaux avec les
rougeurs les poissons sont ceux qui sont
les plus fréquemment utilisées dans la
recherche biomédicale
mais ce genre d'événement
est absolument rarissime
pour comprendre ce qu'il s'est passé il
faut imaginer un poisson de 50 cm rouge
et blanc qui sillonnent un grand
aquarium de 3000 litres
je m'intéresse à l'apprentissage chez
les poissons
c'est du moins ce que je vous ai dit
c'est ce qui avait écrit sur la petite
annonce à laquelle vous avez répondu
votre travail est le suivant
chaque fois que le poisson passe dans un
cadre orange vous devez le noter
c'est la consigne je vous ai expliqué
qu'il a été conditionné lorsqu'une
lumière verte s'allume lorsque des
bulles remonte du fond de l'aquarium il
est censé se diriger plus fréquemment
vers la partie cible ce périmètre orange
la revois n'en voit plus on le voit on
voit peu c'est un jeu d'enfant ce qui
rend les choses plus difficiles
c'est que vous devez injecter un produit
nocif dans l'aquarium se produit c'est
un euro stimulant le pire à cette âme
qui est censé
intensifier l'apprentissage le problème
c'est qu'il est toxique vous ne savez
pas encore mais l'animal qui
m'intéressent
n'a pas de nageoires il n'a pas de
branchies il est assis devant un grand
aquarium
et c'est vous
il y a
trois ans j'ai voulu lancer un nouveau
programme de recherche
je voulais comprendre
comment ce qu'il se passe dans la tête
de personne à triland ordonne de blessés
de faire souffrir et de tuer un animal
pour la science
comment nous être très sensible doté de
capacités empathique très développé
faisons-nous pour objectiver réifier
chosifié un être vivant
j'ai construit un protocole inspiré des
travaux de stanley milgram un chercheur
américain qui diront les années soixante
à yale aux états unis s'est intéressé à
la soumission à l'autorité
milgram à recruter dans son laboratoire
un millier de personnes qui devait
administrer les électrochocs elle
victime non consentante
en réalité un acteur dans mon étude la
victime se serait un animal marin un
poisson
750 personnes ont participé à l'étude
imaginez vous à leur place vous êtes
devant une console avec 12 boutons et
vous devez appuyer sur les deux boutons
l'un après l'autre chaque bouton
rapproche le poisson d'une mort certaine
le deuxième bouton est mentionné risque
de mort 100 % ce qui rend les choses
encore plus difficiles
c'est que vous entendez le feedback
cardiaque du poisson devant vous
l'électrocardiogramme part en vrille les
bips sonores qui traduisent l'activité
cardiaque sont de plus en plus
inquiétant de plus en plus erratique
vous aimeriez arrêter mais quelqu'un
après de vous vous dis il faut continuer
un chercheur vous incite à poursuivre le
protocole
voici une illustration vidéo du
protocole très rapidement
après l'expérience tous les participants
ont été terribles débriefer et ils ont
eu l'occasion de raconter ce qui s'était
passé leurs réactions ont été très
variables vous allez voir j'ai senti que
le poisson santé dans la douleur plus à
l'est et plus je le trouvais méchant
parfaite et on empathie avec le bois
sont des durs se dire que
qu'on va le faire crever quoi c'est l
observer des péris à voir mourir c'est
contre mes convictions sensible ça veut
dire que ça me fait chier de faire
souffrir quelqu'un ou un animal sur ces
violences est sourd hague
j'aurais pu me laisse à désirer contre
mes idéaux donc je vais en vinifiant en
train de tuer un poisson et en même
temps ouais ça un petit pouvoir me sens
pas moi mon coeur des besoins de plus
vite au fait que j'entendais son coeur
bat de plus en plus discret ça nous a
menés à partir quoi on voit qu'il
ressentait qu'il était tenté des choses
ouais j'ai jamais de là un peu la
compassion je sais pas je n'étais pas
déçu pas senti très bien pas très fier
j'aimerais que le poisson je sais que du
poisson 1 j'aime pas faire des espèces
d'animaux que ça normal déjà d'une somme
à stresser j'ai cru que j'allais arrêter
as a way 50% je me suis dit bon comme si
j'étais à sa place je suis étonné de moi
même version que celle que j'ai appuyé
sur un bouton j'ai tué se passe on est
mal que je pourrai manger donc normal
que je pourrai manger alors je ne
conseillerais pas cette personne de
ramasser le poisson mord dans l'aquarium
de le glisser dans un sac isotherme
de rentrer chez elle avec le bois sont
de le poser sur la table de la cuisine y
ajouter un trait de blanc un peu de
villes du citron et des herbes et de le
mettre au four thermostat 7
je dois vous dire que aujourd'hui les
produits marins sont problématiques
on nous dit qu'il y a des métaux lourds
du zinc cadmium du cuivre du nickel dont
les animaux marins et je dois vous dire
que mon poisson avait le ventre
littéralement bourré d'électronique
des moteurs des capteurs une batterie
pour pouvoir sillonner l'aquarium
pendant des heures en évitant tous les
obstacles il était recouvert d'une
matière formidablement souple et ferme
dont certains humains se font à planter
dévouent pour pouvoir produire une
meilleure impression plastique du
silicone
c'était un poisson robot et voici sa
peau
un robot mais vous ne saviez pas
seulement 15 % des participants ont vu
anguille sous roche
la plupart ont mordu à l'hameçon ce qui
m'intéressait c'était de comprendre
justement comment un être vivant pas
mettre en jeu son empathie face à un
autre vivant qu'il doit sacrifier pour
la recherche
l'empathie telle disposition humaines
fondamentales qui nous permet de
comprendre et de ressentir les états
mentaux d'autrui elle nous amène parfois
apporter de l'aide parfois inhibé des
comportements parce que nous savons
qu'ils blessent les autres
mais le problème de l'empathie
c'est qu'elle est sélective elle est
très limité elle s'applique souvent à
des autres nous même
les animaux sont du mauvais côté de la
barrière on les attaquait les a ni dans
une sorte de bulle
contenant près de 9 millions d'espèces
que nous opposons à l'humanité avec un
grand h
nous avons créé une césure métaphysique
entre eux et nous
cette césure nous empêche très souvent
des trouvé de l'empathie pour eux nous
sommes l'espèce animale qui est fière de
se voir comme une espèce non animale
alors pour les animaux s'il nous
ressemblent un peu c'est plus facile
avoir deux pattes
c'est une bénédiction
comme cet homme de vitruve mais ce n'est
pas à l'honneur de vinci en avoir quatre
est une imperfection
en avoir plus de 4 est une aberration et
ne pas en avoir
c'est une malédiction en tout cas pour
les poissons dans leur monde liquide
éloigné avec leurs yeux plat leurs corps
vis que des poissons mérite t'il notre
empathie
ces poissons si loin alors pour
comprendre l'empathie que nous avons
pour les animaux il ya trois grandes
dimensions importantes la première cette
dimension zoologique c'est à dire la
distance évolutionnaire
entre eux et nous des chercheurs du
muséum national d'histoire naturelle ont
construit une carte des locations
empathique pour les animaux ils ont
présenté à des participants des photos
de différentes espèces très diverses par
exemple à l'hippopotame un hippocampe un
orignal un ornithorynque un pingouin une
fourmi et les participants devaient tout
simplement dire pour quelle espèce il
éprouvait plus d'émotions et pour quelle
espèce il ferait le choix s'il fallait
n'en savait qu'une des résultats ont
montré que plus le moment de coupure
révolutionnaire était éloigné plus
l'empathie est trouvée pour les animaux
étaient faibles
une autre étude
a consisté à présenter à des
participants
des sels de maltraitance animale filmé
par exemple une scène où un primate un
faisan ou un crapaud était maltraitée et
à mesurer le stress des humains qui
voyait ses scènes à partir de capteurs
physiologiques mesures ont un indice de
stress la sudation
d'un résultat a montré que plus ces
espèces animales était proche de nous
plus le stress était important le second
facteur qui explique le comportement
avec les animaux c'est le facteur
culturel nous avons assignés aux animaux
les places les plus variables du
piédestal à la niche ou à l'assiette
prenons l'exemple du chat
incarnation de la déesse bastet il a
fait objet l'objet d'un culte durant des
siècles en egypte ancienne
lorsque dans la famille le chat mort est
on se rasaient les sourciers chez les
égyptiens
et puis
on a également durant le moyen-âge en
france durant nos fêtes nous avons brûlé
vivant des chats on a fait le commerce
de leur pelage jusqu'au xixème siècle
et ce n'est qu'en 2020 que la chine l'a
retiré les chats des animaux comestibles
aujourd'hui dans france le chiffre
d'affaires des aliments pour chats et de
plus d'un milliard de renvoyer cette
trajectoire de perception et de
comportement avec les chars haïti le
troisième facteur c'est le facteur
individuelles nous sommes très
différents les uns des autres selon
notre histoire notre personnalité par
rapport aux animaux par exemple les
femmes sont 39 fois moins enclines que
les hommes à battre gravement des
animaux il ya également d'autres
facteurs je vais y revenir mais d'abord
revenons à l'expérience
imaginez que vous avez participé à votre
avis jusqu'où iriez vous personnellement
sicile à dire lorsque j'ai demandé à
1600 personnes extérieures à l'étude de
se prononcer
en moyenne les gens étaient très peu
nombreux à penser qu'ils iraient
jusqu'au bout seulement 12 % ont affirmé
qu'il tuerait le poisson quatre fois
moins que le résultat observé 53 % 20 %
ont refusé de commencer et tous les
autres sont distribués entre ces deux
pôles
parmi ceux qui ont refusé de tuer le
poisson ou qui se sont pas arrêtés plus
tôt il y avait
plus de plus de femmes classement rennes
est plutôt plus - d'omnivore et des
personnes qui avaient une tendance à
créer une césure moins importantes entre
les animaux et les humains cela
s'arrêtait plus tôt également gagné
également des études qui ont consisté à
mesurer chez les animaux
en tous cas chez les humains leur
perception de la capacité cognitive et
intellectuel des animaux en fonction de
comportement qu'il venait de réaliser
par exemple une étude australienne a
consisté à faire consommer à les
participants soient des morceaux de
boeuf séché soit des noix de cajou et
ensuite les participants devaient
évaluer les capacités cognitives et
émotionnelles et sensitive des animaux
est également se prononcer sur la
considération morale qui voulaient leur
attribuer les résultats ont montré
qu'après avoir consommé du boeuf séché
les participants avec tendance à minorer
mes capacités sensorielles de la vache
et à déprécier son inclusion morale
alors dans l'expérience dont nous avons
vu que les participants étaient nombreux
53% à aller jusqu'au bout et ses
résultats sont modulés par des traits
individualités personnes qui avaient un
niveau élevé à une échelle d'empathie
proposés aux participants avant l'étude
par exemple un de ces items mesure
l'empathie pendant partie émotionnelle
réactive et bien aller en moyenne moins
loin de rendre protocole de même des
personnes qui adhéraient à une vision
égalitariste de la société allait aussi
malouin comme si finalement à ses
capacités sociales étaient présentes
dans le monde humain finalement ça
s'appliquait également dans nos
relations avec les amis
une question reste encore en suspens
concernant l'explication de la solution
autorités face à l'expérimentation
animale pour mg le chercheur de galles
qui a créé ces recherches sur la
soumission à l'autorité
l'individu finalement renonce à sa
responsabilité et se transforme en une
sorte de robot d'exécutants qui file à
m'en fais ce qu'on me dit de faire mon
hypothèse très s'est pas complètement
vrai c'est à dire les gens d ici parce
qu'ils ont en perspective des idées
qu'ils chérissent des normes culturelles
ou des valeurs ils sont importantes bien
sûr ils obéissent par l'effet des
circonstances mais les buts de la
situation compte beaucoup donc j'étais
c'est cette idée en amenant 50 % des
participants à rédiger un essai dans
lequel et devait trouver des arguments
favorables à la science en quoi il se
sentait proche des scientifiques
pourquoi la science est importante et à
50 % des participants je leur ai demandé
de faire un essai plus critique
vis-à-vis de la science en quoi elle
peut poser problème et j'ai montré que
les participants qui avaient été
amorcées dans une perspective pro
scientifiques avaient davantage tendance
à
sacrifier le poisson
il ya quelques minutes je vous parlais
de ses yeux cet oeil qui est tombé du
poisson durant l'expérience
maintenant vous le savez c'était un oeil
de verre un oeil de taxidermiste mais la
participante qui l'a vu tomber par
accident et bien ne s'est pas arrêté
pour autant
elle a simplement dit mais que ce
produit est toxique
et ce qui est très touchant je trouvais
que d'autres participants au contraire
voyant le poisson dans son aquarium en
train de se faire empoisonner
eh bien regardez ses yeux et c'est à
cause de cela qu'ils sont arrêtés
d'injecter
le produit trois ans on regarde on a
l'impression d'avoir une conscience en
face en fait est de voir le
respect de liens qui se créent en fait
vous prêts quelque part près ce qu'on se
met à sa place les unit poisson mais je
sais pas ça m'a touché enfin je sais pas
j'ai senti quelque chose on sait déjà
comment regard affolé on peut rechercher
un bête parce qu'il avait les yeux tout
écarquillés qui meurent là est de plus
en plus désespérément
si un jour devant vous vous voyez un
oeil qui tombe
vous saurez qu'il a peut être une vie en
jeu
quoi qu'il en soit concernant la
considération pour les animaux quel que
soit leur nombre de pattes
ce qui compte le plus ce n'est peut-être
pas leurs yeux mais nos yeux
que voyons-nous dans les yeux des
animaux ou peut être
qu'ils voyons nous c'est ce que m'a pris
mon poisson en plastique en électronique
en tout cas tout va maintenant vous
rendre vos yeux et vos oreilles merci
pour votre écoute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]